فوارغو صواريخ وقضائي فوق قنابل عنقوديه
هذا بعض من حصيله الضربات الروسيه على
تركيب وحدها ثروه من الادله فالروس
يحاولون طمس اثار عدوانهم على اوكرانيا
حتى جثث قوتهم لانها في يوم ما ستديح
لاوكرانيا تقديم روسيا امام محكمه دوليه
والارقام
يعني همم
يربط المحققون الاوكرانيون حطام كل صاروخ
بضربه محدده وبضحاياها المحتملين وبفضل
المعلومات الوارده على الرقائق الموجوده
داخل السلاح يقيمون مخزون عدوهم
حرج من احتياطي الصواريخ حتى الدفاع عن
بلدهم اذا حاولت دوله ما الاعتداء عليه
للمره ثانيه تدوي صفاره الانذار الجويه
هذا اليوم ما يشير الى ان روسيا مستمره في
استراتيجتها بتنفيذ ضربات صاروخيه واسعه
نطاق
يعتقدون انهم يؤذوننا
انفسهم
يمكنهم التخلص من بقايا هذه الاسلحه لكنهم
يفكرون في عرضها داخل متحف ففي هذا الموقع
وحده توجد صواريخ قدرت قيمتها بحواله 100
مليون دولار لكن قبل ان تطلق وتتحول الى
حطام